hello everybody I'm Alex I know it's the
last talk of the first day and probably
tired there's no more Martha left but
stay with me for 30 minutes and I'll
give you web performance optimizations
straight in the dev tools when I pitch
this this morning
karma said I'll pick talk from the
audience I haven't changed my mind so if
someone wants to volunteer web site they
want me to take a look at don't be shy
I'm sorry your honor
come on stage and spell it out for me
I'm happy to do that but it has to be
pg-13 the whole website has to be pg-13
go for it things in this world I
volunteer for Mozilla as a Muslim reps
and Mozilla tech speaker you've seen a
fellow tech speaker come up on stage
today and talk about his dance dance
revelution but I like the idea of a
paycheck so I also have a day job as a
JavaScript developer advocate for next
Moe anybody heard about next one before
okay two people that's all good
did they cloud communication api's I'm
not going to talk about that I'm going
to talk about web performance and when
we talk about web performance most
people focus on javascript optimizations
and that's kind of sad because web
performance has like three stages where
JavaScript organization is the very last
one of them so whatever you do to
optimize your javascript it's still
gonna be micro micro performance
optimization if you don't optimize the
first two chunks we're gonna look at all
of them we're gonna open up dev tools
the website and I'm gonna power up three
of the tools I'll use one of them is
Network the other one is memory and the
other one is actual performance so let's
take a look at the very first one let's
look at Network because that's when you
want the website into your browser
what's the first thing it happens it
gets the DNS tries to look up what you
want and then this just images no it can
be right okay so it looks up what you
want out of the out of the website and
starts bringing it in so if I look at
that I'll see as soon as it loads I have
a bunch of images that start loading
after the the Jason the J's files load
now I can look at each one of those
requests individually I'm not gonna do
that I'm gonna look at the ones that are
problematic this is one of the the
really optimized ones so for example I
look at this when everything took 33
milliseconds this javascript file took
500 milliseconds that's huge all you
know all I had 91 requests with three
and a half megabytes but only one point
four of the Oh one point six of those
was transferred transferred and that's
because probably the website has
something like jay-z ping so I get one
point six megabytes and then it expands
on desk I don't really care about the
actual size on desk I care about the
transfer size because that's what comes
through the network to the browser so
I'm gonna look out of those or it still
loads it says it finished in 30 seconds
which can be right so that means it's
still loading I'm gonna look at the big
one so if I look at it I can see it's
JavaScript I can see content headers and
a bunch of other stuff about it I don't
really care the token is strangely small
but what I really care about is the
timings because when you when you ask a
resource from the internet yet the
reason it says blocked right there is
because the browser can't handle all the
connection
your website wants to make it goes and
does DNS resolution first it starts
connecting to the IP it does the TLS
setup it sends the little bit of data
that I want back and then it waits for
the server a really long time and then
the server sends back that micro
javascript thing and if you look at at
this the things I can't really touch or
optimize are the DNS resolution
I don't really control where the DNS
comes from on the client side the
connecting bit that means your server is
halfway around the world your IP is
halfway around the world you don't have
a CDN I can connect to you don't have
something that's close to me for example
if you're using EU West or whatever
that's Frankfurt it should connect in a
millisecond the TLS setup I can't really
influence a lot about that it just has
to do with your connection the same way
so if you're connecting is gonna take
long your TLS is gonna take long because
just connects a bunch of times to the
same thing the sending part is
instantaneously cuz I'm not sending a
lot of data if the sending part was huge
that meant probably I was sending form
data or something on the network and
then I wait for the server like for at
least a quarter of the time and that
means your server isn't fast the server
has too many connections it has to
handle at the same time and the
receiving bit is instantaneously the
things that I really care about are the
sending and receiving and that those
happen fast the thing your user sees is
rate my browser block my HTTP request
because there were too many in the queue
so depending on the browser there's a
limited number of connections and how do
you resolve that instead of loading when
I started it loaded like 20 images out
of 90 requests or something
make that one or two I won't see them
anyway that above-the-fold why do I need
to connect and get them before I get
your JavaScript if it's JavaScript I've
got someone in there I can see the JSE
quest-19 JavaScript requests why can't
you make one it's JavaScript the
firelight and it doesn't really matter
so compress all that into one minified
if I look at CSS
CSS looks better and it looks like only
one is from your domain and the other
one is from Google that kind of makes
sense you can't unless you get the
Google Fonts in locally with your CSS
then you can make one request ah I'm
gonna look at images which is the bulk
of it why do you need to send me 65
images from the load time I can't see 65
images on the page send once and two
sprite them if you have to send a bigger
chunk you don't lose on connection
because if you look at the server timing
you can see the stuff I'm waiting for
just to go and connect to the IP every
image takes just as much as as much time
for that and then it sends four
kilobytes I probably lost more time on
the connection than on the actual
transfer of those four kilobytes sprite
it with something else or for this I
want to see what's a 4 kilobyte image
right did you really need this to be an
image it's 4 kilobytes so if you look at
this this is the the big part of
performance the first part of
performance because no matter how fast
your website actually runs on the client
it depends on the time it takes to get
to the client and any react fans in the
room right ok yeah you're not gonna love
me the last time I use create react app
I had 20 20 megabytes of JavaScript why
do I need 20 megabytes of JavaScript
don't get me wrong once it actually
starts it's fast I'll give you that
react is fast but just the fact that
it's big makes the user load experience
more than 2 seconds does this there's a
bunch of of papers online that say if
your website loads over 2 seconds you
start gonna you're going to start losing
users I wouldn't advocate for 2 seconds
because a bunch of people read the 2
second rules and some of us might have
might have been forced to slow down on
websites too low
two seconds instead of milliseconds just
because if it's instantaneous you users
gonna think oh it came from cash it's
not fresh let me do shift refresh on it
but I advocate in under three somewhere
in between and that means you have to
get everything in one go so you don't
keep doing the round trips every time I
do this and every time I look at the
website most of the times fixing this
means more several resources I know
you'll think oh it's the client it's
cheap into whatever we want sometimes
it's not cheap sometimes having to
transfer three megabytes of data
actually cost me money and you're gonna
be upset on your website so you want you
users to be able to say yes they slowed
it fast for me and so on so this is the
first part the second part is the
performance tab so you've got everything
to load on the webpage or you got it
from the internet on the page fairly
quickly and that's when performance
starts actually you can starts to
actually see performance because once
you have the resources the browser is
gonna start rendering them the
connection is one bit as soon as the
first resource hits the browser is going
to start rendering them and doing stuff
with them and that's when you see
performance now the way performance
works is you've got record they make a
snapshot of it and kinda debug on the
snapshot because no website loads the
same twice in a row I don't think even a
just HTML page is gonna load in the same
timings twice in a row some people say
three snapshots some people say seven
snapshots I'll just do one because I'm
lazy here so I'm gonna record
performance I'm gonna scroll around for
a bit and then I'm gonna shift refresh
my whole thing and I'm gonna stop
recording so you see in terms of the of
the website it's not really a big deal
as this like weddings website category
page
how do I do categories this integrity
yeah okay so I'm gonna throw this away
gonna start according performance I'm
gonna scroll and then I'm gonna shift
refresh it someone gonna get fired over
this are the developers actually in the
room right amazing
yes I'll take it easy so you see the
difference between this and the first
page the first page I did this
performance recording and I was one
percent buffer fool I did the same thing
when the category page I was 8 percent
buffer fool and that's because the
browser can only handle so much
happening at the same time when he do
performance or memory you're taking a
toll on the browser network maybe but
not so much you're taking a toll on the
browser so it's actually Firefox is
actually going to show you this takes at
all right so I'm gonna look at what I
did I started scrolling for a bit and
scrolling didn't do a lot of things for
me the color coded I can zoom in if any
further so the whole thing is color
coded and it shows me purple as style
changes and that means I scrolled a bit
some some more stuff came into view I
hovered over bit and then the Styles had
to change for it it's not really it's
not really a problem except I've got a
ton of them and that means out of those
yes as out of that CSS file you've got a
lot of competing rules or you've got a
lot of things that change state based on
where my mouse is and that's why I see a
bunch of recalculating style I actually
only see one paint in the whole thing
which is good so the way this happens is
once you start changing things with
JavaScript that that have to do with CSS
it needs to repaint the browser instead
of just recalculating style because you
basically said I have the CSS style
worked with it and then you start
scrolling about and things happen but as
soon as you tell it tell it from
JavaScript look there's this new rule
for it it's gonna have to do a repaint
because it does not understand where to
put that in
context of the of the styles so that's
actually good it's better than most
websites out there there's some websites
that in the paint category you get right
up paint every few seconds and that's
because you interacted with JavaScript
on the Dom there's a bunch of Dom events
in here or I just hovered on it so
there's a bunch of Dom events in here
that trigger repaint on the browser now
I'm gonna look for it it's just this is
me scrolling Dom events and styles how
do you fix that
how do you stop me from triggering
recalculating style and Dom events do
you really need hover effects on all
buttons if you do I'm sorry it's gonna
take a perform install if you don't you
don't really need to put them in and
want to look at the page to the point
where I think I refreshed here right so
this is where I started doing the
Refresh what my browser understands by
that as right let's keep the web debate
I was in in sort of a dead zone ready to
decommission it and let's show the new
stuff but the decommissioning bed means
all your JavaScript that's in there is
taking at all
and technically when you're doing
refresh on your website only your
website suffers but most of it is gonna
be oh there is a navigation and a new
page so it actually make you're making
the next page a bit slower just because
I got JavaScript trying to dump the
garbage collection and it's trying to do
it non incrementally and it's basically
saying I don't really care just dump
dump dump let's get a block of thread
for a bit and then after I did that it
started loading the new bit and the new
bits come with sty recalculations
I don't understand what I do function
calls and that probably means your
JavaScript starts doing things as soon
as it hits the page do I want to know
what's it built in do I want to look
under the hood are you gonna tell me is
it react No thank God right so it still
means your JavaScript starts doing stuff
to the page as soon as it loads
the timeout beds are the ones that keep
popping up let's look at what so if I
actually want to see what's the
offending piece of code I can every vent
has something tied to it and this for
example once I click on it it opened the
debugger for me so I can look at the
line of code and that's I set my my
script is loaded config whatever I
loaded something and that's the piece of
code that made that specific trigger if
we go back to it I can look at what
maybe
right done event that's the load Dom
event that means the the Dom even loaded
page triggered my only problem with it I
see twice so I means you finish loading
it and then it is something more in
JavaScript and it load it again I
strongly advise you to do dum-dum load
it just maybe once because it's enough
and whenever you do load loaded unloaded
it's going to start doing recalculating
status is gonna figure out I missed
something class panic and do it again
the new browser engines are a lot better
at this if this isn't your thing this is
kind of a hard to visualize because you
see you see the type of events and I can
see most of the events have to do with
the Dom in the first part because I
scrolled around a bit and the second
part it's just doing stuff stopping
doing stuff stopping doing stuff
stopping means you're lazy loading
something using javascript and this
you're getting a good frame rate per
second which is like 50 anything between
30 and 60 is acceptable anything under
30 is not if you're doing game the stuff
on the web you would really want to go
for sex to your video stuff like that
you can visualize this whole thing and
different ways so you can see it as a
call tree and it shows you let's see if
I can make it
knob
you
maybe so it's you can see every piece
javascript that interact on your page or
every piece of code in a three down view
so you can see what's the down to the
level of right this is my most offending
function that takes the longest it's a
single one
it's PDP GS I don't know what PDP does
but you can figure out right that's my
problem I'm gonna focus on this one of
the other things that the flame chart is
if you want to see it and see this is
probably the like you can figure out
where I did refresh because this was
linear and then I started doing a bunch
of different things at the same time and
that's basically the point where I hit
refresh regularly your page once it
loads it's going to do stuff linearly
and that Styles JavaScript and stuff
like that if you see this it means
you're doing either a single page app
that hits the net will give you a few
times and it's reflashing the view or
you just reloaded the page so I told you
this was the recording one of the things
that I find cool about the the
performance inspector is you can
actually import so if you do this in a
team which probably most of you probably
are if you if you care about perform or
if you get to that point with your app
where performance is an issue probably
have a big team it's really hard to work
on performance in a team just because
your recordings are going to show
something and your teammates are going
to show something slightly different
every time but with the import feature
so you can save this recording and use
that as the baseline for the entire team
and then you can all work on the same
data instead of having to oh I created
slightly different data problems so
Network and performance performance has
to do just a tiny little bit with
JavaScript and it's mostly a job my
JavaScript is triggering out other event
or streaking out other other stuff or
it's oh I need a garbage collector what
happens when you want to go down to
JavaScript level to function level to
see where it eats up memory there
is the memory tab this was where it's
kinda the same way in except you don't
record your memory you take a stop
snapshot of it so they have to record
anything it's gonna go and grab as much
memory as it can and then figure out
what what the memory is used for see if
I look at this I took a snapshot and I
can see visually I can see where my what
my memory is going and that means my dom
nodes do five megabytes of memory that's
not a lot with about 5,000 dominoes do I
want no way I have 5,000 downloads and
means whenever you create a new element
or whenever you hide it and close it and
stuff like that it interacts with dom
whenever you change the properties on it
a new domino gets created in memory and
probably on the page you have close to
200 300 maybe but it means in memory
every time you do something with those
300 notes they get multiplied and
multiplied and multiplied you strangely
have two documents on a page most
websites have one and that means you
triggered you triggered the dom loaded
event that means you trigger the
downloaded event twice so the first
document that was loaded was saved in
memory but then we loved it the other
one it said oopsie I need to create a
new document for you see how both in
memory right now even though one isn't
doing anything the script is the next
big offender after that so this is
zoomable so you can see exactly what
scripts are taking up most of the memory
I'm gonna look at the biggest one the
lazy loading PDP is the the ever
offending PDP that is that's the biggest
one and then the just-in-time compiler
is eating some of the that memory up as
well apparently you've got no file name
that means you have inline styles
somewhere in your HTML but anything got
part of the page the Google tag manager
that usually shows up if you want
analytics analytics it could be going to
be a big chunk of your of your script
and then you've got objects it's a given
you work with JavaScript that keeps
object in memory most of the time it's
functions objects that you have problems
with but if you go down the stack you
can see for example if your regex
regular expression heavy and stuff like
that it eats up the memory the strings
that's not really important everybody
has strings you could probably cut it
down with using glass spaces in your
HTML and stuff like that the other is
interesting though you've got weird
stuff the JavaScript engine is going
like object group and shared and shape
which D the profiler doesn't know how to
interpret it comes down to your using
custom classes in your JavaScript and
that get bundled up into other so I've
showed you how to do I've showed you how
to do network performance to get you as
fast as possible to client rendering
performance on top of other things and
then memory performance the only part
where JavaScript actually matters in a
micro performance optimizations matter I
mean here which you're not doing too bad
if you look at the different website
mine has many many more JavaScript I
think maybe 100 lines and of course dev
tools failed why wouldn't it it's a live
demo so if you look at mine you can see
my script is actually smaller than my
strings it's minimal but I have my Dom
nodes are big and this is a static
website with maybe maybe 100 lines
hundred and something lines of HTML tops
and that still shows as 763 count
whereas your showed 5,000 and you can
look at that the stuff you can improve
if you want to go down to actual
JavaScript performance you saw the
performance bit
right
so if you want to go down to the
JavaScript level you can
but your browser dev tools isn't the
best tool for it like network
performance and memory are not the best
way to trace all your JavaScript I
actually think the console is the best
way to trace your JavaScript but I'm
running out of time yeah I'm running out
of time so I'll stop here for a bit
I think the console is the perfect way
to basically debug your JavaScript and
there's two things in the console API
which help you a lot and that's console
that time and console that time and and
that takes you how long your JavaScript
executes or how long how long it took
between these points in your execution
and the other stuff is console that
trace console that trace isn't gonna
work as I have an anonymous function in
here but console dot trace shows you
every function you have to pass through
or skip through to get to the point
you're at now and that means this
function gets called at the first level
at the second level and at the seventh
level of my execution this is the thing
I'm gonna optimize first if it's one of
those oh this thing actually maybe gets
called once every blue moon
I'm not gonna optimize that I'm gonna
stop it here if you have questions now's
a good time I still I think I still have
like two minutes for questions yes
perfect yes it's a blank page no the
whole point that the whole point of
performance optimization is you optimize
you can't make it perfect you have to
make trade-offs every day do you want
images images are usually big you need
images for your website is this business
critical well it's gonna be big at least
you can load them either five at five at
the same time all in one or you can load
them bed by bed by with streams and
stuff like that
Oh via WebSockets keep a connection
alive if you're doing seven images the
HTTP keep alive and since seven images
on the same connection instead of having
to renegotiate the same connection over
and over and over again
cool any other questions
yes the marketing stripped right so
scripts scripts are usually static even
Google Analytics you can download Google
Analytics run it bundle it with your own
script the problem with the script is
usually well you need analytics you're
going to live with Google tag manager
you saw that was a chunk it's one of the
trade-offs you want at hyper performant
you give up analytics which I wouldn't
do to be honest I wouldn't do I like
analytics I like knowing how my website
performs outside of my little bubble I
wouldn't trade it for that but the 17
that you can change because it's
probably three external and 17 that you
make seventeen that you change that's
the bulk of your performance
optimization nobody says you can make it
perfect but you can take care of the
stuff that you can influence for example
you don't control the hosting or you
have to go to DevOps to control the
hosting it's not really a front-end
developers job to control the hosting or
the server you're running in but it's
something you can see and you can debug
you don't have to necessarily fix it you
can have someone else fix it but you can
say hey this is a problem and I think
that's time and I'm gonna thank you
[Applause]
[Music]